hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to one night at flumpty's -
now the first part of this game is
actually the best five nights at
freddy's Colonna i've ever played
it's horrendously scary and if you
haven't seen it already I recommend
watching it right now links in the
description but this one people are
saying is even better than the first
it's still just one night and still
things are taken not so seriously but
hey that's a good thing oh well this
isn't fun at all what the hell is going
on here wait a minute why is piglet all
ripped open why is Freddy's head on
there haha
still works Oh No okay so there's a vent
there's a cheetah there's a face there's
a thing and there's a front door okay
that's not what I was expecting
oh god I'm gonna die so badly is he
there oh crap oh okay oh this is nuts
I'm not gonna be able to do this
am i okay so drive ends oh oh oh oh no
oh no no oh no oh no oh yeah oh no no
this is gonna be bad I can't think of
words to say other than I'm [ __ ]
because that's pretty much the long in
the shorter what's gonna happen here
holy [ __ ] oh crap why is that it okay so
I can't let it run out of batteries or
else it has to go through a startup
sOooo
okay so no okay there's flumpty there
there's what's-his-face
okay so I'd why is there facing the wall
right there I don't think I mouse
activated so I don't know this is gonna
be about all right
okay all right well that's okay all
right Oh God yeah that's disgusting
it's an eyeball egg is that what's
inside flumpty okay so I wasn't ready
for that and I wasn't paying attention
to what fan I was looking at therefore
it didn't do well for me oh this is
gonna be a fun game isn't it oh boy I'm
not gonna be able to beat this people
were saying that this one was harder
than the first and I actually had a
tough time with the first one cool great
song loved it except for one I hated it
oh man there's a clown over there
I don't know that clowns gonna do
something to me I mean pretty much
everything here is gonna do something to
me okay
oh that uh-oh I kind of remember to not
let my power run out or else I'd love to
restart oh man this is so creepy
it's like creepier than the original
five nights at freddys or nothing like
oh my god it's so cute see - okay
hey flumpty you're way over there though
okay so I row hey how's it going okay so
I really cannot let it run out of power
or else I'll be screwed well what why
that's okay
bye okay what was that that was the run
thing from the other game but I mean why
was that a thing oh hey clumsy you're
over there ain't you so should I turn it
off now I don't know I don't know what
I'm supposed to do why is there's no oh
god wait that wasn't there before the
was with the wiggly worm of ketchup on
the wall
I'm not going crazy eyes I say I think
think oh die okay that's cool you
spelled out die on the floor there yeah
I think I think things are changing from
what they were before oh [ __ ] womp
that's what you get that's a ditch for
that okay so I think I'm okay but I know
this game cuz I played the first one
that things are gonna change the night
goes on things are gonna change like a
son of a [ __ ] hey how's it going there
I'll cancel that if that's as easy as
that takes and that's gonna be pretty
easy to handle oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
where's flumpty oh I couldn't see where
flunky was I only had one logical
collusion to make that's a good that's
bad sound I was about to say that's a
good service that's the opposite
oh we G open his eyes no we do Luigi has
a flag over his head you son of [ __ ]
I'm not able to judge things accordingly
because I don't know where everything is
yet my muscle memory - oh man I can't
believe there's a hard-boiled mo to this
I'm never gonna be able to beat that
what's with the drippy drops at the top
of the ceiling this doesn't make any
sense
what's with you hey flumpty hi how's
gone oh [ __ ] god damn it I forgot okay I
just got to get by yeah that's got to
get by Oh floppy walrus funny
okay okay all right cool
so like the instinct is when the when
the birds on his way you might as well
just flip-flop or no maybe that's trying
to catch you maybe that'll just catch
you off-guard because you're not suppose
I owe
where's the dude yes okay I guess right
okay bye
nicely animated leaving walk good for
you
why is there no don't tell me the clown
oh no don't tell me the problem me too
bro me too okay that was very little so
I can't let my exposure meter go all the
way up or else I'm gonna be boned and
boned is novel I was like okay that's
bad there's so many things to take care
of oh [ __ ] no I said no you go away now
you go right away so am I not supposed
to look at that room at all
or is that a thing that I'm supposed to
do because this problem I don't know
what I'm supposed these [ __ ] they
got no patience son of a [ __ ] patience
okay it's all right it's all good so
whatever I got reactions like a clap
yeah man all right Bert all right now
[ __ ] you didn't see me looking at me
ain't good for your health
cuz I'll punch you in the dick [ __ ]
yourself lofty okay
join the party here all right cool wow I
am NOT gonna be doing well here oh it's
just a normal counter oh I got to keep
track of the counter
I have no effect on it that's cool is
gone I can count in my head it's a
useful skill so he's over there
flumpty's about to pop out Freddie it's
really paying off
oh I'm not happy about that thunk wonk
he said they're both on the right side
you almost got me there my exposure
meter
it's almost done so yeah you better
wander off okay his patience is about to
run out
flumpty patience oh [ __ ]
go away go away go away go away thank
you okay I don't know if I can I look at
oh I can look at it just won't charge
when I do it at night or when the lights
are off not at night it's probably at
night anyway but you know what I mean
[ __ ] this is really stressful like all
the rules and controls is so
well-balanced it's so well crafted it's
good oh that what the [ __ ] is that okay
five am piece of [ __ ]
wow so close dammit it's so stressful
it's so stressful teeth you forget I got
thrown off by the giant red eye face
monster again hi I don't know okay cool
all right great that was the thing glad
that happened great glad that happened
hey lumpy I was cutting the recording so
that I could restart it with the mouse
cursor enabled so that you could see
where I was clicking because it's
important when I'm trying to highlight
stuff and flumpty was just staring at me
so it's 12 a.m. and I've already turned
it on to hard mode because holy [ __ ] I'm
an idiot have it easily it was gonna
happen I'm probably not gonna win this
one but if I do that would be amazing
[ __ ] okay damn it I sucked on that one
come on I did that but it didn't but so
what
you gonna sue me [ __ ] you a flop the IU
and you do it on the year you're on the
wrong side and everything is fine oh
that's not fine everything is now fine
well I thought oh I got an instant
message from a guy I hate write 500
whatever the unit of measurement that is
it's not seconds that's for damn sure
oh god damn it I was off I [ __ ] it I
didn't get that yeah I know it looked
very impressive like I almost did that
at will but in reality I was why our
focus going your friendly [ __ ] good good
guy he's a good guy he's good guy that
guy I like that guy lot he's a good guy
feel your rage enragement child come
after me brah
okay bye thank you
[ __ ] come on but the vents are coming
okay no I don't know why that is that
must be like the equal patience is about
to run out there is my glove was a
little earlier hey I hate to admit it
but it happens to the best of us yet
he's on his way he's about to make his
way oh [ __ ] what does that mean I don't
like that what is happening now is a
stupid silly silly game this game is a
silly one [ __ ] game is a silly sue but
I'm gonna win it I'm gonna win I'm gonna
win [ __ ] go away okay so that's I got
that down and I'm almost done [ __ ]
the burnout kill me oh [ __ ] why why I
don't know why I don't know why oh [ __ ]
go away
I'm almost done with this [ __ ]
okay come on 6:00 a.m. come on I'm the
other Adam okay that one's locked go go
away [ __ ] [ __ ] okay damn it oh cool
nice 8-bit NES screen sorry flumpty
bumpty okay close one night at flumpty's
- but that was the easy mode there's
also a harder mode available which if I
know anything about hard modes in five
nights at Freddy's games it's gonna take
me a long long long long long time to be
baby the way I'll play it and I'll find
out where the end of the game actually
is and what it leads to because I like
this game it's great it's phenomenally
made it's wonderful it's like a
tongue-in-cheek thing about five nights
at Freddy's but it works so well it's
actually terrifying
so either way this is one night at
flumpty's I'm gonna play hard-boiled
mode let me know what you think about
this game like I like this I like this
so much because it's so well refined
like there's so many elements there and
I'm wondering if hard-boiled mode is
gonna add more gameplay to it because
there's a lot here and there's a lot to
like so hope you guys enjoyed it thank
you everybody so much for watching and
as always I will see you
Hey